well then why do then why does the lower
income population have more children if
they make more money they have less kids
yeah it's a club
what do you mean it's a class thing
involved it's like you know
educated
informed people tend to make more
educated informed decisions and so
but that's the scariest child right and
so they would have less children as
opposed to uneducated people who would
but you would think that people who make
more money would have the majority of
kids because they can't afford them and
the people who don't have money would
have less kids because they can't afford
them yes it's not what's happening but i
i just don't think it's sustainable if
if if we carry on with kind of the
traditional mindset of like yeah
everyone should have firstly i don't
think everyone should have kids i think
there are a lot of people who aren't
developed enough as human beings to have
kids and i think one thing that's
overlooked with the you know traditional
family narrative
um
traditional family structure narrative
is that you know everyone had kids and
everyone was all happy